the forecast was three to six percent
and the actual result of the data was
3.7 percent a bit more than expected 0.1
percent more and the markets haven't
reacted to it just yet because New York
hasn't opened yet they're gonna open in
a few minutes that's why I'm gonna try
to
um keep this video a bit shorter than
usual so I can upload it faster so you
guys can be ready okay above you have to
remember that tomorrow we also have
unemployment claims retail sales PPI
data so tomorrow we're gonna see lots of
news announcements too now
um you know CPI coming hotter than
expected that's basically berries for
Bitcoin okay because it's showing you
that economy has a problem and the SMP
what they see how it opens today let's
say the future is what it's doing so far
all right so far I can see a gap here
maybe we'll come and fill this Gap later
today okay on the way to four thousand
four 160 but as I was saying you know if
inflation come Hotel unexpected that
means that the economy has a problem
and SMP is gonna react to it all right
and in principle it should go down now
if the s p goes down Bitcoin in theory
should follow okay so uh that's the
first thing also dollar should move up
but we talked about this in yesterday's
video there is no much Confluence or
moods are not confident sorry
correlation between the dollar and
Bitcoin this week because if you go to
the dollar
they're gonna see how you know since for
example the
first of September is is going up that's
the only thing that all that index has
been doing basically going up you can
see it since the first of September now
we go to bitcoin what has Bitcoin doing
since the 1st of September that's the
first of September okay literally
nothing
26 000 and right now we're at 26 100.
literally hasn't moved okay
it's gone sideways up down sideways down
up sideways it hasn't moved all right so
it's it's quite tricky in a normal week
you would already be preparing shorts in
Bitcoin okay but we have the problem
that Bitcoin is not really following the
dxy at the moment okay so you have to
try to think a bit more outside the box
first of all
what is bitcoin not going down
or why is this correlation stopped well
what I kind of see is that Bitcoin is
then sold in some kind of a strength or
that then it has a motive to go up first
before coming down right and that is
these two liquidity pools over here okay
so those two liquidity pools I'm still
gonna be looking at them I know
expected I'm also expecting something
like this I still okay this was my
prediction from the Bitcoin soon the
update all right and so far you know the
fact is drop not the recovery job above
the 4 Hour 50ma last night before going
to bed I took a little scalp at 25
870 was and then includes this morning
right before CPI uh 26 100 something all
right that's a little one percent move
and then you know when it was CPI I
closed my position to reduce risk uh
because the volatility and so far
nothing has really happened to be honest
okay I was expecting to be more of
action maybe I'm getting used badly okay
because look what happened on Monday and
Tuesday but anyway what I'm expecting is
still something like this okay and
you're gonna notice that we go to the
Daily time frame
you can see how we have there the 50 EMA
in the daily time frame okay so this is
still a zone of Interest that's at 27
000 okay we're gonna try our Market
there in in white okay so we can see
that is there and if we go to the one
hour time frame
there is something that tells me that
Bitcoin might still go up or at least
you know prepare a stockhold and it's
basically this week over here check out
that week
dark week needs to get felt okay guys
that week needs to get filled now in
order for that week to get filled
I would like to see Bitcoin let's go to
the four hour time frame I would like to
see Bitcoin not sorry 15 minutes time
frame
15 minutes time for that I would like to
see Bitcoin look at 115 time frame you
can even see that more clearly okay
that's a huge week guys
in order for this week to get filled I
would like to see first some kind of a
stophunt this could happen either in
today's New York session
if we see some action or if not we could
see this between today and tomorrow okay
and I'm gonna give you
my idea of the market at the moment okay
it might be right or it could be
completely wrong but this is how I'm
gonna try to play this okay you might
have a little retrace book
asonkers were holding above the one of
50ma
what about guys
if this is up you know a pump
retrace you came here to the 150 Ma and
also the 450 May and then continuation
okay
and this could happen between today and
tomorrow then you could see in this Zone
some kind of consolidation and then if
tomorrow the new sarbat that's when you
can see a dump okay
and this pretty remote aligns with my
view
since Sunday as you can see here in jail
okay that was my view on Sunday
um still to be honest it wouldn't
surprise me and I'm betting on this move
so far okay that doesn't mean that I'm
going long here because we just got bad
CPI so I'm not gonna be opening Longs
okay I'm trying to understand what is
the best place in the chart to open
shorts okay and I'll tell you in a
normal day I would think okay CPI sort
of unexpected price is gonna go down I'm
gonna open shorts in this soon boo
tomorrow we also have news announcements
Bitcoin has lost some kind of
correlation with the dxy
why not why couldn't we see today
you know maybe a retrace to the 150 May
or the four or 50 m i don't care and
then we could still see this pump guys
consolidation
works for the upside by Price cannot
cannot go any further and then they drop
all right
so so far that's what I'm looking at now
what is the zone
that I will be looking at opening shorts
or what I think that if there is a new
Spike up
how far can it go okay uh what I think
is basically that uh between that one
hour 50ma that would be the highest
point okay if we break above this then
my short scenario would be invalidated
because I would say
that will be invalidated because I would
say you know you've broke above a
variational resistance as the daily 150
support that I'm out I'm fully out of
that short okay but
what I think so far that would be
my my top okay and then you have this
week
so I think it's gonna get filled so
somewhere
between this one okay that's the song
and obviously I would like to see this
happening
before the news announcements tomorrow
right
so something like this guys
that is
what I would like to see
to happen in Bitcoin in the next 24
hours all right something like that guys
again am I completely wrong anime just
do know instead of this
we might instead
you know go down straight away and
retrace this pump during the sensation
or also you could say that this looks
like an information okay
there you go
and then price you know could fill the
50 of this week or 100 and then dump but
I'm looking for some kind of a spike or
stophunt collects you want
between this week
on The Daily 50ma all right so that's
between basically twenty seven thousand
and 25 500 500 Zone that's what I'm
going to try to prepare some sorts
if I see the opportunity okay so
um that's basically what I think of
Bitcoin in the short term
basically uh for this week all right
guys and I would like to take you to
high blood Capital to see if the
liquidity backs up my theory all right
so let's go there want to have low
Capital let's do this really quickly all
right so the Delta is showing that there
is six billion dollars worth of long
liquidations all right and you can see
how the biggest amounts of liquidations
are to the downside
basically long liquidations all right so
it matches so my point is
six billion dollars is that enough
that's a question of the way right is I
enough liquidations to drop price
aggressively from here liquidate six
billions or could it make more sense you
know to push price a bit higher
maybe this can get all the way to 10
billion dollars you know above this week
and then drop and hit these two
conditions here at 25 700 25 488
um 25 200 all right so that's what I'm
thinking in the short term if you go to
the liquidation heat map
they're gonna see how
there is a bunch of Liquidations in this
Zone and again please guys notice the
same behavior and what we've been seeing
in the three months time frame how is it
possible about Bitcoin didn't hit this
Zone just yet look what happened last
night they hit all the way to 26 550
with a week
but they didn't really hit 26 650 where
there is where there are more
liquidation so
you know if you notice what they've done
is you know Spike price or but not hit
those liquidations then drop
right and now price is trying to climb
back up
and in this move you can see how this
one has got brighter there are more
liquidations at the moment okay
so why not guys what couldn't price hit
this Zone in the next 24 hours between
26 650 and 26 800 maybe on the way to
the Daily 50 about 27k that's also the
mid range of this range that we are
currently on all right and then drop
aggressively backup by bad news
announcements tomorrow so that's what I
think for Bitcoin in the short term
again
and this might go down a straight away
or maybe it goes Urban all the way to
the Sun and then drops we'll see what
happens bro this is my
um Market perspective at least in the
short term
we'll see what happens when New York
opens today I'm expecting some
volatility to be honest I would like to
see some action probably maybe a
Retreats first
you know to drop some shorts because you
know they come to the idea on the on the
chart to say you know we've got bad CPI
and now New York is dropping I'm gonna
open short I'm gonna write those
recorded Contours and that's when you
just could trap then that could be the
stophunt of the New York session and
then bring price back up
right and then eventually hit this Zone
maybe knowing the same exact session but
maybe you know again days in session
double Asian poop I don't know guys
maybe I'm going crazy but that is pretty
much everything that I want to say today
and before I finish the video let me
remind you that we only have a couple of
days left until this campaign finishes
I'm paralleling with being X it's one of
the top exchanges and one of the few
ones that doesn't require kyc
um it takes a couple of minutes to
create an account and the campaign is
that if you register through the
referral link and you deposit at least
fifty dollars and keep it there for at
least three days you get basically fifty
dollars for free okay 20 for registering
30 for depositing fifty dollars and keep
in there for three days and also you can
get another hundred dollars if you trade
over five thousand dollars in trading
volume but that would be basically be
for example
imagine five traits with a hundred
dollars in terms 10 leverage okay that's
uh five thousand dollars telling volume
so if you're looking for a new exchange
then you have an opportunity this
finishes on Friday and that's pretty
much everything guys so thank you so
much for watching and I'll see you soon